Morning folks. How are you? I'm going to
go long here
of the four contracts on initially and
I'm going to put this stop opens at this
candlestick's low right there
right there plus a minus a tick or two.
Okay.
And then uh we'll look to add two more.
U I'm inside this here. I'm trying to
view this as a inversion fair value gap.
It's a little disorganized this morning,
but uh we'll see what we get.
I think we're running back to midnight
opening price for New York. Uh now, if
it can come back down and kiss the high
of this inversion fair value up again,
I'll add two more contracts.
I can raise the stop up now. Just below
the midpoint of this. Let me get ready
to add those two. Come on. Come down
here. Give daddy a kiss. Let's go. Come
on. Come on. Come on. Come on. Come on.
Come on. Come down. Come on. Just a
little bit more. Come on.
And there you go. Thank you so much.
Just for good measure. Another one here.
I'm watching this wick right here.
So, if you grade that, I don't want to
see any bodies buried south of its
consequent encroachment level. So, we're
going to get rid of this, this, and
this.
And we'll make it blue right there.
Okay. So, I don't want to see the bodies
buried. Well, it can do this. That's
fine, but it can't leave the body below
it. I'm actually going to add
two more to that simply because we came
back down into the deep end of this gap.
So, it should now start on this candle
or the very next candle. It needs to
show immediate willingness to go up and
gravitate towards taking out this
short-term high and this short-term
high. And as you can see, we are not
using market replay. Okay?
[clears throat] Market replay is not
required. If you know what you're doing,
you don't need market replay.
All right? So, this wick, let me let me
make this broader so you can see it.
[snorts]
It's a little disorganized this morning.
Uh, we have a lot of heavyhitting
[snorts]
uh news
on Wednesday and Thursday, CPI, PPI.
So, this wick right here is underneath
where price is and where I started
entering my orders. You can see where I
got in at the low end of that inversion
f gap there and we add it all into that
or at the high right where I told you I
wanted to see it do that. So my average
across all those orders is essentially
the high of the inversion fair value gap
there.
So now I can raise the stop up to
the low of the inversion fair value gap
and minus a tick. Okay. So I reduce some
of the risk
and now we're just in striking distance
to take out that minor
side there
and then we'll be looking for analation
to the upside above that little
short-term high. Okay. So same business
I was explaining down here with this
wick. uh we want to see the same kind of
thing happening here. This is the higher
one.
So don't want to see any bodies buried
below that. So that's it's normal for it
to come down and hit this. And then we
want to see no bodies below it. If it
does, it needs to show a willingness to
go immediately higher on the next
candlestick.
Preferably, we want to see it above
close above it. There you go. Like that.
And now we want to see this one. It can
flirt with with the lower wick. can do
that, but it's better if it's if we're
on side, it won't take out that low.
It'll just rip higher. Nobody's below
this line.
That's how we're looking at it. Or
that's my let's say it this way. Uh
that's my interpretation of what we're
seeing in price over real price action,
not market replay. I don't have the
benefit of knowing what's happened
already. I have to be on the hard right
edge and it would be like this. Okay,
you're watching it like that. That's how
I used to trade when I first started.
That's how everybody had their charts. I
was like, we don't have much room to,
you know,
imagine what could happen. You you got
to have a little bit of empty space out
there where you can kind of like
formulate an idea or a vision of what
price could do and still be okay with
the idea going higher or lower relative
to your expectations.
All right. So, one more time, it's
kissing the inversion fair value gap.
Actually, I'm going to add on that
because I like it.
So, we have this wick consequent
encouragement and this wick consequent
encouragement there. Uh, you're probably
going to see the body close in between
these two price points here.
Body actually the
close there, but it's better if it goes
up like it's doing.
We just don't want to see any lower body
movement.
I know it's needing it.
He talks about what should or could
happen and the market just like it
listens and just does those types of
things. That's experience. That's but
that's the language I'm teaching you.
And if you understand the language,
you'll be able to sit in front of the
candlesticks like this and watch them
live. You don't need to do any market
replay stuff. Okay?
And now we want to start to start really
ripping higher.
We want to see it close above here. Soon
as it closes above this, then I'm going
to roll the stop to cover costs.
And because I'm teaching through the
medium of a paper trading account, there
really is no cost here.
Why do you teach with a paper trading
account? Because I'm I'm licensed to
give trade advice. And as much as I love
teaching all of you, I'm not opening
myself up to litigation because I'm not
putting in into trades. I'm teaching
price action. Okay? Same thing I did
when I was doing paid mentorship. I was
teaching price action. That's all this
is.
All right. So, we want to see it really
extrapolate above this. And then we want
to see it get to midnight over night
midnight rather. um Monday's New York
local time midnight price
where we opened up at and that is seen
over here
right there
at midnight on that candlestick right
there.
So open is 29,878.25 25 and that's what
we get over here. So, we're looking for
that. Uh, this is the pre-market
session. I'm going to teach you this
later in the afternoon, so don't worry
about that.
I got you covered.
Okay?
And
obviously, the best case scenario would
be to see it go up to Monday London
session relative equal highs that buy
side. Uh, but I'm going to take off.
Um, let's take off
five just below that
midnight opening price.
Okay. So, that's that. And now we closed
above. So, I can roll the stop to cut
costs.
All right. Not bad. Not bad, old man.
So, we're looking at the
potential to get to and through midnight
opening price. Uh if it goes there and
comes back down in uh my stop is at the
location where it's pretty it's pretty
sound cuz what am I anchored to? I'm
anchored to the high of the inversion
fair gap that was already used. It was
qualified
here.
Confirmed. Confirmed. Confirmed. And now
we're way up here like we were expecting
to see it do. and no reliance on market
replay. As you can see, it's again all
live price feed. Everything's happening
on their hard right edge. I don't have
the benefit of knowing what's already
happened. The countdown to the
candlestick close. You cannot do that
with market replay on Trading View. Try
it yourself. You'll see. And I'm showing
you the entirety of my screen. There's
no there's no buttons down here. I mean,
look. I mean, here's the time. Click on
that. Where's the buttons? that tells
you you can press play for market
replay. It's not there. Okay.
So, that's that. [snorts]
So, it's important if if you're going to
learn my smart money concepts, it it's
it's advantageous for you to know you're
learning from someone that knows how to
do it. And since it's my stuff, I I
pretty much know it, right?
And anyone that teaches through market
replay, I think is someone that needs to
up their game. And if that means it's
one of my students, then that's what it
means for them, too. It's there there's
no exception to that rule because if you
understand what you're supposedly
teaching, you'll be able to do it a reli
price feed and walk it out. All right.
So, we have a little bit of a buy side
and balance, sell side, and efficiency.
I'd be I'd be
pleased to see some of this stay open,
meaning like this right here.
It's not inherently bad if it completely
fills it in because we're still low in
the in the cycle of of the run, but we
want to see it preferably leave
something open while being bullish still
because that's one of the strongest
signatures that the market's still
likely to go higher cuz it's leaving
these little tiny spaces like this
of that gap. This is the portion that
was left open. You see that?
So, that's the type of stuff we want to
see in there. see how it's behaving and
it's running right up into first
partial.
And at that point, you know, it it
doesn't matter what the trade does, then
it doesn't make a difference if it comes
all the way back down to stop me out um
on the final portion. It doesn't make a
difference to me because it's done what
I hoped it would do as a initial idea
for investment.
Okay. So, there's that. No market
replay. Okay. [sighs]
Uh the midnight opening price is
something I teach. It's like a magnet.
It's a very strong draw on liquidity and
anticipating and and looking for very
specific characteristics in price action
leading towards a bias. Okay? It doesn't
need to be the daily bias, but a session
bias. Okay? Like for instance, this
morning the market opened at where we at
here 9:30. Right there. So we opened
right there. See that? And it just so
happens to be very close proximity to
the high of the inversion fair value
app. And then the market behaved by
going lower,
tripping people short. One more time for
anyone that wanted to use that low as a
breakout go short. Okay. And smart money
would buy those initial sell stops. That
rallies up, goes back above on this
candlestick. It qualifies and confirms
this candlestick to this candlestick
right here. That's a bearish fair value
gap when bullish becomes an inversion
fair value gap. That's confirmed right
there with that close
and then it trades back down through it.
Inversion fair value gaps can see this
happen and then rallies back through
this candlestick we close above. So I
have two qualifications for this now
while expecting it to go higher.
The next candle we open, we trade down
and then back up. New closure on the
high of it. So that confirms this open,
trades down, comes back up and closes
here. So that qualifies two times this
inversion per bag gap after it gives you
what you're looking for before you
anticipate utilizing it for entries.
Notice that my entries are here, there,
and all of these are all inside of this.
They're not just at that closing price.
There was some down in here.
And then right there in the upper
quadrant, I told you I wanted to add cuz
I like that. And it was going down here
and it could not even touch the
consequent encouragement of the
inversion fair. Notice that. So if this
price right here, look at it like that.
Right
there. What's that price say in the
black price axis? 29,796.25
and the low
96.25.
So it's it didn't make it there. See
that?
So we ripped through as we were
expecting these relative equal highs.
Then we want to see a strong
extrapolation above this with a higher
close. We got that there. I told you I
wanted to see some of this gap that is
indicated by this. This is the
inversion. I'm sorry. This is not
inversion. It's a bullish fair value
gap. when we're on side and we're
expecting price to continuously go
higher, which it could and we're I'm
leaving the the invitation for higher
prices still with my position being
still open. When we see a buy side,
bounce sellside sign efficiency like
this, we don't want to see it trade
completely down because then it makes it
harder for it to prove that it wants to
keep going higher versus by leaving that
small little portion open like it did
then it got to my first partial and
midnight opening price. So, same thing
in here. this
this little gap in here with the volume
imbalance.
Perfect world, we want to see it leave a
portion open or don't even trade into it
at all. Then it acts like a breakaway
gap or measuring gap
in deference to where that gap forms
from the inception of the price run,
which is clearly down here. But then
utilizing the smart money concept to
anchor in and like tether yourself to
the idea that order flow is bullish and
then then look for high probability
areas to enter and to participate in
that. All right. So we have seven on.
I'm going to take this and set it up so
I can do singles for partials in the
event that I feel inspired to do so. uh
if we can get above
the intraday high I have here
and then we take out let's go to the
left again scrub through here so we
already bumped above here so the next
order of business is this
could act well it is so far holding
price down a little bit it's inversion
on this right there and the next one is
this
so we could see a A little bit of
messiness in here. So, we have two
potential inversion fair gaps against
strong gap and a gap that hasn't been
tested yet. We just got down to the high
of it there. And then we have a minor
buyside liquidity pool right there.
So, let's take a look at that.
All right. So, we have buy side at 29,9.
We'll just call it 920.
So, I'll take a
I'll take two off
just above that.
I think that's reasonable if it can get
there. See how I told you it can get a
little messy in here? Made its way up
into that inversion fairway gap over
there that formed at uh 7:29 this
morning.
>> [sighs]
>> I'm going to
increase my paycheck
to just below that wick high right here.
So that way if it turns on me at least I
banked a little bit more in the price
run.
I'm looking for admittedly I should have
probably took off one there for teaching
purposes, but my interest is if we can
get higher and draw to those overnight
swing highs that are relatively equal.
I'd prefer to see that.
And I don't want to empty the magazine
on everything this far lower than these
relative equal highs. So we just went
down to consequent encroachment here on
this small little B side of bounce
outside efficiency that has a volume
imbalance at the high. So we want to see
it really if it can close above half of
this wick which is consequent
encouragement
that would be bullish
to watch this level in here. I know
there's a whole lot of lines here folks.
Let me just take some of this stuff off
cuz
I was doing measurements and
left them on.
Got wrapped up in the commentary. So in
this gap, you can see that we've had
this much oops this much left open. See
that? So this candlesticks high
and this candlesticks low. That's the
portion that's been left open. Part of
this inversion fair. I'm sorry. I keep
want to say inversion fair gap a bullish
fair that has a volume and bounce at the
high end of it. You see that? So either
this candle or the next one needs to
start really marching higher.
See that little volume and bounce right
there? As a reminder again, no market
replay. Okay. Everything's the hard
right edge.
I know I know some of you like these
kind of teachings, but then the others
that are here to just want to hurry up
and learn how to do something right
away, and they're not trying to learn
why it should work, when it will be
problematic. Uh they they tend to be
I I get they're they're resistant to
longer videos as if their trading is
going to be inside of five minutes all
the time. Like if you're going to trade,
you watch someone that's managing and
then managing expectations on price
action. So what we're doing is we're
predicting. Do not listen to people that
say don't try to predict, learn to
react. Don't listen to that. That is
exactly what retail is trained to do.
Retail is trained to react. I'm not
teaching you to react. I'm teaching you
to anticipate. So this wick right here,
we're watching that now.
That is PDA number two.
If we close below that, the last bit of
defense is this swing low, which is why
I have my stop loss
just below this wick. Okay, see how we
came down and hit the consequent
encroachment there. It would be
wonderful to start seeing it really
rally higher out of that.
We closed just south of that bullish
fair value gap, but we closed above in
the upper half of this wick. So, we're
balancing several things here. Okay, if
this can completely climb back above and
close above its opening price on that
candlestick here. So in other words, a
close above the open on that price. If
it closes above 873.75
or in this call 874 even then it should
resume going higher. Otherwise I have to
endure all of this and potentially get
stopped out and it's okay. Remember I
took five contracts off here at the
midnight opening price part of a
position size of seven contracts. So
just about half of the position, not
quite just as small as you can get
beneath the halfway point of uh 12
contracts.
So even if it comes all the way down,
stops me out, it's it's a win. It's
nice. I had a free look. I got paid, you
know, hypothetical $4,000 plus to see if
they can go go higher. There's nothing
wrong with that.
And and here I don't have any immediate
concern for now see this wick here. We
want to see this body close above that
midpoint of that wick.
See how I'm giving you all the details.
Um Al Brooks doesn't do that. Okay? I
know there's people out there say, you
know, he teaches uh one candlestick at a
time, but he's not teaching what I'm
teaching you. You'll never hear him say
say that kind of stuff. I promise you it
doesn't exist.
>> [sighs]
>> So, if we close above that midpoint
level, that's actually uh positive. If
it closes above this opening price, it's
extremely positive. As I was indicating
moments ago,
why do you have to talk about other
traders? I'm not trying to be
disrespectful to other people, okay? Oh,
he just read my mind. What I'm saying to
you is is I read other people or they
will contact me and they'll say, um,
what do you say to people that say you
did this or you copied that or you
learned it from this person or that
person? Um,
that's why I respond the way I do. So,
we did get a close above that opening
price. Okay. And now we want to see it
close above consequent encouragement of
this wick. Once it does that, then I
want to roll a stop just below that low
right there.
So far, midnight opening price is
offering a whole lot of initial
resistance. You see that [snorts]
it spent a little bit of time north of
it. went go went lower, tried to get it
off on this run here, this one needs to
turn around or the very next candle
needs to show some strong willingness to
go higher.
And when you have things like this, you
can do um you can do a stop loss. You
can do two contracts as a stop out right
here. I have five seven on rather. So if
I get stopped out with it going below
that low, it's kind of like taking a
partial on a retracement. It's not
ideal, but if it's going to come back
against me, I'd rather take two off here
and only have five if it comes down to
the full stopout. See what I just did
there? So, I'm teaching application and
real world what the market's doing based
on what I have to deal with based on the
price action. So, there you go. I took a
partial. I didn't do it on the the ideal
side of the curve, which is throwing it
above market price while bullish, and it
reached to it.
That's ideal. But in this case where it
could potentially be coming back against
me and to also teach you how to manage
those emotions, those psychological
tugof-wars that take place, just put a
stop loss in on partial. I had seven
contracts net long. I put two contracts
on a stop right here. So if it goes
below there, it's going to sell two of
the seven I had as a partial. So now I
put more money in the bank, proverbial
bank of this position by doing so. And
it's lessened the load mentally on me on
having the need for me to be right. You
see what that does? It completely
subdues
the the aching of please go to my target
or please don't stop me out. You're
managing the position. You're managing
it. Okay. So now we have this wick right
here. If it goes below that, you know,
the only thing it's supporting is the
remaining portion of that. And I have my
stop loss right below there. So, if it
comes down, stops me out. It's okay.
It's okay.
Now, what you're going to do is say,
"Well, why didn't you take off more
here?" Or, "Why didn't you do something
right here? Why you?" Because I'm
teaching you the process that I went
through and what I go through when I'm
in a trade.
you're not going to be able to get the
best of the best.
You're simply not going to do that. So,
you have to learn to navigate and have
rules and protocols and procedures and
processes that lead to a decision-m
based on you predicting what is likely
to happen. Notice that I'm not reacting
in panic once it went below that low. I
already anticipated and predicted it's
probably going below there. So, if it
does, let me get paid two more
contracts. and it came back and stopped
me out. Now, overall, let's look at the
price run. I told you we were probably
going to get some messiness in here and
we at midnight price. So, all of this is
formidable resistance.
And then this is the reason why I
navigated the way I did. I said this
stop loss below here with two contracts
of the remaining seven I had on at the
time. To me, let me get rid of this
limit order.
it made better sense for me to just put
a stop loss on two contracts of the
seven I'm long on. So, if it stops me
out, it also gives me
more intel because if it stops it out
and then we have a close below the gap
here one more time like it did there,
then we're probably going to go all the
way down and I'll let that stop happen
so that way you can see it in my own
hands. Managing it this way, it's better
than just simply saying all of my stop
loss are nothing. I'm gonna get all my
target rather or or get a full stop out.
I'm not going to take partials. Partials
is for you stupid people. I've read
people that say stuff like that. If you
don't allow the trades that you're part
of pay
in any means possible,
by any means necessary, okay, you're not
trading, you're gambling. You're
insisting that your will be done in the
marketplace versus making an allowance
for your idea coming to fruition, but
not reacting emotionally. You're
predicting. You are predicting things.
Okay? So hopefully this has been
insightful to